I actually have some good news to start with
today.
We have been sort of worried that not enough
people in the United States, in other countries
as well, but we've been looking at the numbers
in the United States that not enough people
in the U.S. would want the coronavirus vaccine,
which would make it really difficult to get
to the herd immunity that is necessary for
life to really start going back to normal
in the context of the pandemic.
But the good news is that every single week,
the percentage of Americans that want the
vaccine and plan to get the vaccine and would
accept the vaccine were made available to
them is going up.
And that's excellent.
That number is now at 71 percent.
71 percent of Americans say they would get
the vaccine.
And remember that just months ago, only 40
percent of Americans wanted it.
And that crept up to 50 percent, 63, 63 percent
about a month and a half ago.
And that number is now at 71 percent.
And the poll that shows 71 percent is from
before Joe Biden and Dr. Anthony Fauci received
their first doses over the last 36 to 48 hours,
which hopefully will push interest in getting
the vaccine up even further.
Now, the 27 percent that remain hesitant about
this vaccine, there's a few characteristics.
These are a few different groups.
So those who remain vaccine skeptical are
disproportionately Republicans, disproportionately
those 30 to 49 and disproportionately people
who live rurally and disproportionately black
American who who are the most vaccine hesitant
groups.
Now, the reasons why each of these groups
is hesitant about the vaccine differ.
Some of the primary reasons are fear of side
effects, fear that the vaccine is too new,
which can mean a lot of different things.
But that's the way they described it.
And among black Americans, the primary reasons
for vaccine coronavirus vaccine hesitancy
are general distrust of vaccines and concerns
that one could get coronavirus from the coronavirus
vaccine.
Now, in terms of states, I don't this is not
super surprising, but there's some interesting
data points here based on data from the IHT
from a few days ago.
The states where residents most want the vaccine
are Vermont, New York, Minnesota, Washington
State, California, Hawaii, Virginia and Colorado,
followed closely by sort of the rest of the
northeast states, plus North Carolina and
a few others.
Now, on the other side of this, the states
who residents least want the vaccine at the
absolute bottom of the list are Mississippi,
Arkansas and Wisconsin.
Now, I'm guessing that there are particulars
about why Wisconsin is there.
I don't know if maybe Wisconsin has a number
of different religious groups and sects there.
I don't know if there's one that is overwhelmingly
anti vaccine.
I'd be interested in knowing more about that.
But Mississippi, Arkansas and Wisconsin are
the most the states most least interested
in the coronavirus vaccine, followed by a
number of states like Texas, South Carolina,
Georgia, Alabama, Ohio, Indiana, Oklahoma,
Kansas.
So there's quite a long list in sort of that
lower but not lowest range.
So bottom line, it's good that the numbers
are up to 71 percent.
I do want to remind you the vaccine is not
going to be given to kids anytime soon.
So when we talk about 70 percent of herd immunity,
we're talking about the whole country.
So 71 percent of adults wanting and getting
the vaccine eventually doesn't get us to 70
percent of the entire country.
We still would not be at herd immunity.
But these are the best numbers we've had since
the start of this thing.
And that's good.
The public campaigns to say I got the vaccine
and people posting pictures on on Facebook
and social media, Dr. Fauci, getting the vaccine,
et cetera, that does seem to be working because
getting a vaccine in the abstract before anybody's
getting it is not likely to appeal to as many
people as getting the vaccine that my twelve
nurse friends got and posted on Facebook about.
And that's certainly helping.
Now, as of this morning, 777 thousand Americans
have received the first dose of the vaccine.
That's zero point two, three percent of the
U.S. population.
It's a start.
But again, unless and we're expecting to unless
we ramp up the number of vaccines going out
and being used to inoculate people, every
week goes up.
It's going to take a while.
It's.
Going to be a process now in terms of more
vaccines, remember that currently in the US
there's the Pfizer Bion tech vaccine and the
Moderna vaccines that have been approved.
The Moderna vaccine is just now starting to
be given to people.
And then we have the AstraZeneca Oxford vaccine
close to possible approval.
And then behind that, you've got the Novavax
and Johnson and Johnson vaccines moving ahead,
pending results.
So in the end, whatever the polls say, start
distributing it, get it to people, keep the
process moving forward, and we'll keep evaluating
month to month and really week to week.
Now, an important note, and I don't understand
this yet.
I've seen the data.
I don't I haven't interpreted the data, even
though states have now.
It's been several days, in fact, more than
that since states received their first shipments.
Many states have only so far actually used
10 to 15 percent of the vaccines that they've
received.
Now, I express concern that we don't want
to see lots of vaccines just sitting around
and not being used.
And a lot of this is getting the logistics
up and running.
And I understand that.
But over time, if if we are seeing that states
are sitting on a bunch of vaccine with lack
of clarity or poor execution in terms of actually
getting it to people, that will be a concern.
And we'll cross that that bridge when we come
to it.
But the urgency can't be exaggerated.
Another 3400 people died yesterday of the
virus.
Absolutely tragic numbers.